in this video we're going to discuss
authorship
the main advice on authorship is to
think about the authorship before you
write the paper
especially if you're the person drafting
the paper
think about who is going to get
authorship think about what the order
will be
go through that with the team so that
everybody is on the same page
and nobody feels slighted later on there
are two questions that you have to
answer with authorship
first of all who gets authorship
who are you going to include as an
author on your paper
according to the international committee
of medical journal editor's
recommendation
authorship should be based on the
following four criteria
first the author must be someone who has
substantial contributions to the
conception or design of the work
or the acquisition analysis or
interpretation of data for the work
second the author must be involved in
the drafting the work
or revising it critically for important
intellectual content
third the author must give final
approval of the version to be published
and finally the author must agree to be
accountable for all aspects of the work
and ensuring that questions related to
the accuracy or integrity of any part of
the work are appropriately investigated
and resolved
the main criterion here is that if you
are an author listed on the paper
then you are taking public
responsibility for its content
that's a high bar it means that if later
the paper is found to have a problem
if it's found to a fraud if it's
retracted
you are responsible you are liable for
those transgressions
and that is going to reflect badly on
you
so if you are not the primary author of
the paper before you accept
co-authorship
ask yourself the question as to whether
you want to take that level of
responsibility
do you really understand the ins and
outs of the paper well enough
you have to decide whether you have been
sufficiently involved with its content
to feel that you can take public
responsibility
if you're the one writing the paper and
trying to decide on authors
keep in mind that most people don't want
to be included on your paper
unless they have been fully involved you
can always put them in the
acknowledgement section
if you think that they have assisted in
part of the study but not sufficiently
involved to qualify them to be co-author
there is also the issue of order what
order with the authors appear in
in general order implies the author's
relative contributions
the first author is usually the person
who wrote up the draft of the paper
might have been the person who collected
all the data often a graduate student or
a junior person
and the last position is usually the
senior author the head of the lab or
research team
or the senior person who oversaw the
research
that's a position of stature as well
sometimes you'll have dual first authors
if maybe two graduate students worked on
it together equally
in between the first and last positions
you should put everyone else in their
order of their contributions if it's not
clear if the rest of the authors
contributed equally without much
differentiation
you could consider putting them in
alphabetical order or even reverse
alphabetical order
and sometimes you get these large
working groups with lots and lots of
people in international collaborations
those large working groups can be cited
as a group because they often comprise
hundreds of authors
papers also have an acknowledgement
section
that's where you are going to cite any
funding sources
if you're a graduate student who is on a
certain fellowship
make sure you cite your funding source
there if it was a grant funded study
you're going to mention the grant there
this is also a good place to acknowledge
people who you don't feel merit
authorship
and who probably don't want to be
authors on the paper but maybe they gave
you some materials
or they offered some statistical
consulting or some other advice
it's a way to acknowledge those people
without making them take on the role of
author
there is also an ethical issues of ghost
authorship and guest authorship
this is a hot topic particularly in the
medical literature
it's been written about in the new york
times and it's had some pretty profound
influence on the medical literature
it's important that you are aware of
these practices
obviously they are to be avoided when it
comes to authorship
a ghost author is a professional writer
who usually a company hires to draft a
manuscript
at the end of the day the writer is not
listed as an author on the manuscript
though they may have written the whole
paper
hence the term ghost authorship there's
nothing wrong with professional writers
being involved in the writing process
scientists can certainly use the help of
writers but it's the lack of
transparency that's the problem here
the related type of authorship is guest
authorship or sometimes called honorary
authorship
this is when a company does a study
analyzes the data
draws their conclusions drafts the paper
then they call or email an academic
researcher at a prestigious
university and invite them to be an
author
that academic researchers certainly
can't take public responsibility for the
study
but they're often willing to lend their
name because drug company studies are
often large high quality clinical trials
that get published in great journals
and this goes on the academics resume
the drug company meanwhile gets to
bolster their papers credibility by
leading researchers to believe that an
outside independent
unbiased expert was a driving force in
the study
obviously this is misleading if in fact
the academic was only minimally involved
and is simply lending their name and
their institutions name to the paper
it's unclear how common these types of
unethical authorship
practices are in the literature but a
study in the british medical journal in
2011 that surveyed top medical journals
found
evidence of honorary or guest authorship
in 17.6
of papers an evidence of ghost
authorship in 7.6 percent of papers
so at least in 2011 this practice was
fairly pervasive
if you're interested in learning more
about this the medical community
learned a lot about this practice
because of litigation surrounding the
drug
vioxx merck was being sued over the drug
vioxx
which was defound to increase the risk
of heart attacks
because of the court trials internal
company documents entered the public
domain
and there's a fascinating article in
jama from 2008
where some researchers systematically
reviewed 250 court documents related to
published clinical trial
and published review papers what they
found was shocking
the researchers reviewed emails and
other documents related to 24
clinical trial papers that merck was
involved with
here's what they found documents were
found describing merck employees working
either independently
or in collaboration with medical
publishing companies to prepare
manuscripts and subsequently recruiting
external academically affiliated
investigators to be authors
recruited authors were frequently placed
in the first and second positions of the
authorship list
the use of guest or honorary authorship
was an accepted practice at merck
apparently
they also looked at 72 review papers
that the company was involved in
publishing
they found that merck marketing
employees developing plans for
manuscripts
contracting with medical publishing
companies to ghostwrite manuscripts
and recruiting external academically
affiliated investigators to be authors
recruited authors were commonly the sole
author on the manuscript
and offered honoraria for their
participation
only half of the review articles even
disclosed that merck had sponsored those
papers
that's quite insidious you can see that
this could have profound impact on the
medical literature
merck could actually put this whole set
of opinions and perspectives out in the
medical literature with it having the
stamp of coming from an academic
institution
when it really came from the drug
company marketing people
you can see why this has been such a hot
issue
just to give you an idea this is an
actual internal company email that was
made public during the court trial
it shows you how blatant this practice
is
the company writes to the potential
guest author
i would like to invite you to be an
author on the abstract and manuscript
for this study
we are currently preparing both for
submission before the end of this year
could you please let me know if you
would be interested in authorship on
both the abstract and manuscript
one of the two planned publications or
none
in making your decision you may want to
take into consideration that the results
of this study were negative at first
glance
basically the company is giving out
authorship like a gift
and they're allowing the researcher to
choose whether or not they want to
accept this gift based on how the study
results happen to come out
clearly the author being invited here
has no basis for taking public
responsibility for the content of these
articles
obviously this researcher was not
heavily involved in the analysis
because the analysis is already done or
the writing of the paper
it's already being drafted this is a
clear case of guest authorship
and the trial turned up many emails like
this that made it obvious as to what was
going on
in summary naming authors on a
scientific paper ensures that the
appropriate individuals get credit
and are accountable for the research
deliberately misrepresenting a
scientist's relationship to their work
is considered to be a form of misconduct
that undermines confidence in the
reporting of the work itself
you